[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode the
kos and this is this is kind of a weird
one you understand because a lot of
times when you're doing a spider-man
take because remember this is a full
weeks of spider-man I started my
spider-man collection and I thought
about the iconic villains and you know
the spider-man that I like to use I had
to come across a spider-man himself that
I thought was worthy of my collection
until the spider-man 2099 that's the one
here right beautiful statue amazing
statue so I said what's the first
villain that I can show from
spider-man's Row gallery that shows
spider-man how can I say it properly
a villain hero is only equal to his
villain that that that's what makes a
hero great how great the villain is how
maniacal reveal the villain is how
dangerous the villain is because that
shows you how strong the hero is well
this is this is a weird one because
venom didn't come along too very long
and a tooth in spider-man cycle you see
spider-man was years years and years
without the venom you would think venom
was around earlier than that but that's
not the case you see how I was
introduced to venom coming to
spider-man's universe I believe it was
spider-man
300 this issue right and before that it
was Secret Wars
now Secret Wars came about because they
wanted to sell toys so they had to get a
story concocted around this whole toy
theory you know to get these toys in the
line so they made dr. doom the beyond
then they changed a couple of characters
clothing that Wolverine toys I loved The
Secret Wars toys I had almost all of
them so in the sequel Wars comic book
what happened was the beyond the
omnipotent alien gathered heroes and
villains alike and placed him on his
planet called battle world and what
happened was they you know they fought
so how Spider Man came into contact with
this suit was his suit got the tattered
in a fight
and he saw the heroes coming out of a
hole and you know though I had a new
cake the hall had a new pant and which
is absolutely funny to me all the whole
pants is ripped and I was like yo we'll
check if there's a new costume from how
did I get that and you know they pointed
him down the whole way and spider-man
went into the wrong room put him with
this machine on his head and he thought
of an image I guess or whatever and a
little ball popped out a little black
ball so little did we know that this
from this little black ball we would get
the symbiont all right
so out of this little black ball
spider-man held it in his hand and it
grafted itself on him it
merged on him and flow flowed over him
like like mercury and four times
Spiderman was wearing this black and
white soup and the webbing was coming
out the back his hand and he didn't need
web-shooters because the suit was making
the webbing alright so they get off the
planet they get off the battle world and
they get back
spider-man gets back to the world well
what spider-man didn't know because he
was waking up exhausted every night
every night he'll wake up exhausted what
he didn't know was while he was sleeping
the symbiont will graph this self on to
him and take him web-slinging through
the streets then find out until like he
he saw something in what's going on so
he went to Reed Richards and Reed
Richards told him that the suit was
alive and it was a symbiont and was
trying to bond itself with him and they
tried to shock it off the spider-man
we're using soundwaves they got it off
and Spiderman was happy but the suit
eventually broke out got back to
spider-man and tried to take over
spider-man because it lusted for
spider-man
so spider-man went to a bell tower and
the sound waves in the bell tower
cracked the suit off for spider-man
spider-man thought he was free from it
now here comes this infamous name Eddie
Brock Eddie Brock was a reportable right
and he worked for the Daily Bugle as
well spider-man while Eddie Brock is was
a disgraced reporter because he was
following a story about Sin Eater City
there was a killer mass murderer and he
pegged the wrong person as Sunita he
staked his life on it
his reputation all this stuff and guess
what he had the wrong guy
well Peter Parker had the right guy
because he you know court pictures of
Sunita you know as spider-man and
actually revealed who was Sin Eater
so of course Eddie Brock's reputation is
destroyed he no longer had a job he
couldn't find work so his hatred grew
toward spider-man so he's in this church
and while he's in this church you know
he was lifting a lot of weights at the
time you know trying to focus his hate
you know getting buff in big paws and
then when spider-man was in the bell
tower and left the symbiote didn't die
Krita seeped through the floors and fell
on to Eddie Brock and bonded with Eddie
Brock when it bonded with Eddie Brock's
we got venom vanilla and them right so
that's that's the long and short of it
right that's how we got venom and that's
how venom came into the Marvel Universe
and you know this is where you see the
difference between the MCU from the
comic books that you know it came on a
meteorite from that step failed
spider-man 3 movie and then venom the
the the next venom movie that didn't
even have a spider-man in it but did a
pretty decent and it had a great
depiction of venom well venom in the
books is amazing alright he's an
antihero he started off as a super
villain and he became so beloved that
people wanted to see more of him so he
graduated from just a regular villain to
an antihero so he's like a hero slash
villain you know so so amazing
ok well let's get into this Premium
Format statue that I got from sideshow
and I believe this is one of the premier
venom villain Venom's there's a ton of
Venom's out there
yeah probably one Venom's you have I in
studio I believe did a venom you have XM
that did a venom you have so many
Venom's but I got this venom because I
thought this venom would a captured
venom in this essence bounding you know
coming across the roof
stalking spider-man it has to switch out
heads this is the premiere edition and
it comes with two switch out heads and I
love them I swear the exclusive editions
on this stuff is amazing you know one
word is tongue out you know
with the todd mcfarlane Mike Bagley a
Mark Bagley of face beautiful beautiful
artwork the textures on venom is amazing
himself the suit has the ripples it
looks like it's alive you can see in the
merging with the toes the base I don't
know the base feels like it's metal this
is one heavy statue so the base feels
like it's metal it's absolutely insane I
don't really like the puffer cloud does
the smoke at the bottom I don't get it I
don't understand it but other than that
this statue is truly heavy the statue is
truly epic and this is something that
every spider-man fan and any venom fan
should have well this is the part of the
video when I asked you to like follow
and subscribe and also enjoy but that
join button yeah do that for us and also
go to Lourdes a game in that net we have
a ton of opinion pieces a whole bunch of
reviews there and also we have heart
heart gaming reviews from attic Lord
addict Lord addict is one of the best
video game of gamers today and he beats
these games like no other we also have
the last word with Lord Cognito and Eve
on ttis we can get that looter shooter
news destiny is on the rise and it's we
have so much fun with it so stick around
watch this video and also look at look
at all these wonderful pitches see you
next week and always stay collecting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]